hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in the appendix to his proliga to
any future metaphysics so we're getting
very very close to the end of the work a
Manu
is going to engage with one of the many
critics of his critique of pure reason
and one of the things that he's going to
do in this that he's already done a bit
earlier in the work but I think is quite
useful to go over since K goes back into
it is to
clarify what he means by idealism in
relation to other idealist think ERS and
as it's going to turn out as you'll see
Emmanuel kant's version of idealism is
going to be not only quite different but
as he is going to say towards the end of
this section my socalled properly
critical idealism is of quite a special
kind in that it reverses the usual
idealism and through my kind all a
priori cognition even that of geometry R
first receives objective reality which
without my demonstrated ideality of
space and time could not be maintained
by the most zealous realists right so he
is telling us two things there first is
that realism requires the kind of
critical or transcendental idealism that
Kant himself is putting forward but the
second thing is that what he means by
idealism the term that he's using is
almost directly opposite to opposed to
what other previous thinkers have called
idealism and which the contemporaries of
his own time are thinking that Kant is
perhaps endorsing by using that term so
we begin with this interesting quote
from it uh he says in order to take a
position from which my reviewer could
most easily set the whole work the
critique of pure reason in a most
unfavorable light without venturing to
trouble himself with any special
investigation he begins and ends by
saying this work is a system of
transcendental or as he translates it of
higher idealism and then there's a
footnote here K actually tells us by no
means higher high towers and
metaphysically great men resembling them
round both of which there is commonly
much wind are not for me so he's saying
I'm not trying to raise things instead
he says my place is the fruitful BOS of
existence what is BOS depth that's a
Greek word that's used in Aesthetics but
it also literally means going deeper and
the word transcendental the meaning of
which is so often indicated by me but
not once grasped by my reviewer does not
signify something passing beyond all
existence which would be
Transcendent but rather something that
indeed precedes it a priori intended
simply to make cognition of experience
possible and he says we have to
distinguish here between Transcendent
and transcendental so he's really going
after his reviewer and this prompts him
to ask the question question well what
sort of idealism goes throughout my
entire work what is it that I am doing
and he says uh it does not by a long way
constitute the soul of the system of my
work but it does go throughout the
entirety so we're going to get a really
important contrast developed here
between interestingly what he calls
genuine idealism the the German term
there is act right so authentic idealism
and what is what is the implication here
K idealism is not genuine idealism it's
something different so he says that the
principle that uh the victim of all
genuine idealists from the elic school
so we're talking about Parmenides and
those going onward all the way to Bishop
Barkley is contained in this formula all
cognition through the senses and
experience is nothing but Sheer Illusion
and only in the ideas of the pure
understanding and reason is their truth
now you could also call this a kind of
rationalism as well perhaps but he's
he's labeling this idealism and what is
the dictum uh the principle that is
running throughout his idealism it's the
exact opposite it is a reversal of this
um all cognition of things merely from
Pure understanding or pure reason is
nothing but Sheer Illusion so we have
something being identified as illusion
but in this case it is the exact
opposite of what the other kind of
idealism is identifying as illusion and
only in
experience is their truth so this is a
really important reversal as well as
distinction that is taking place here
and he says this is directly contrary to
idealism proper and then he's going to
address a question that the reader would
you know bring up well why are you
calling what you're doing idealism why
did I use this expression for quite an
opposite purpose why did my reviewer
come to see it everywhere and he says
well you know the reviewer is kind of
sloppy had he actually read it
attentively he would see what is going
on here and so what is it space and time
together with all that they contain this
is K Doctrine are not things in
themselves or their qualities but merely
belong to the appearances of things in
themselves up to this point he says I am
in confession with the above idealists
here's where I'm in agreement with
idealists but here is where the reviewer
didn't pay close enough attention so he
says these and among them more
particularly Barkley regarded space as a
mere empirical representation so an
empirical representation what we get
through our experience a mere empirical
representation that like the appearances
that contain aains is together with its
determinations known to us only by means
of experience or perception so how do we
get to know space first we experience
and then what we do experience is space
and then we construct the idea of it in
our mind but space is kind of illusory
from this perspective so he says um I on
the contrary prove in the first place
that space and not only space but time
which Barkley didn't pay adequate
attention to didn't consider and all of
its determinations can be cognized a
priori prior to any experience
independent you might say of any
determinate experience by us why because
no less than time it inheres as he says
in us as a pure form of our sensibility
before all perception of experience and
it makes possible all intuition of
sensibility so you don't have
sensibility first and then get space and
time you've got to have space and time
first and then you can actually have
intuitions within our faculty of
sensibility so he says then it follows
from this truth rests on universal and
necessary laws that for Barkley so we
get another really important contrast
here for Barkley experience can have as
he says no criteria of Truth and what
does that actually mean to us here uh
its appearances have nothing a priori in
their Foundation there's no sort of
structure there's no sort of manifold we
might say so if this is the case for
Barkley experience is nothing but Sheer
Illusion and I I leave it to you to
decide if you've read Barkley whether
this is really a fair and adequate
understanding of his point of view but
this is what Kant says about it now how
is Kant contrasting his own position on
space and time here is what he tells us
um for it follows that experience uh
with us space and time not only by
themselves and this is very important in
conjunction with the pure concepts of
the understanding right this is
something we saw earlier you need the
categories you need the concepts to be
uh having experience and not just
perception through sensibility so they
prescribe their law a priori once again
outside of experience
to all possible experience and at the
same time afford the certain Criterion
for distinguishing truth from illusion
therein and then there's another
interesting footnote here that we should
in fact take a close look at he says
idealism proper so not K idealism but
Barkley all the way back to the eleatics
and perenties idealism proper always has
a mystical tendency and can have no
other that's the direction that it's
going in but mine my idealism is
designed for the purpose of
comprehending the possibility of our a
priori cognition of objects of
experience which is a problem never
hitherto solved or even suggested in
this way all mystical idealism falls to
the ground for as may be seen in Plato
it is inferred from our cognitions ey a
priori another intuition different from
that of the senses an intellectual
intuition which Kant is rejecting
interestingly some of the later German
idealists will take this idea of
intellectual intuition back up and he
says it never occurred to anyone the
senses themselves might intu it uh
priori so what do we have here we've got
clarifications about what exactly
idealism is we've got two different
styles or brands of idealism the
conscient transcendental or critical
idealism which isn't really idealism in
its proper or Genuine sense running from
Parmenides all the way up to Bishop
Barkley and they are not only different
in kind but they actually are reversals
of each other in what they
presuppose and what they set forth as
the truth of
things